- [Instructor] We're told that
Kayla wants to visit a friend
who lives eight kilometers away.
She'll ride the subway as far as she can
before walking the rest of the way.
First, she needs to buy an
access pass that costs $5.50.
There's also a fee of $1.25 per stop.
This is an expensive subway.
Kayla doesn't want to spend
more than $15 on the trip.
So she wants to know the largest number
of stops she can afford.
Let S represent the number
of stops that Kayla buys.
So first, pause this video
and see if you can write an inequality
that describes how many stops,
or that describes the
situation that describes
that she wants to take
as many stops as she can,
but she doesn't wanna spend more than $15.
All right, now let's do this together.
So first, let's just
think about an expression
for how much she spends.
So no matter what, she's
going to spend $5.50,
so we can write it like this, so $5.50,
that's what she's going to spend,
even if she doesn't take any stops.
And it's $1.25 per stop, and
S is the number of stops.
So the amount she's going
to spend just from the stops
is going to be $1.25 times S.
So it's going to be plus $1.25 S.
This is the upfront she has to spend,
and this is how much she's
going to spend on stop.
So this is an S right over here
and I wrote a five right next to it,
they look kind of similar.
And we know that she doesn't
want to spend more than $15.
So she's willing to spend up to $15.
So this total amount that she spends
has to be less than or equal to $15.
Or if we didn't write it
with the dollar symbols,
we would write 5.50 plus 1.25 S
is going to be less than or equal to,
or needs to be less than or equal to 15.
Now that we've written this inequality,
what is the number of stops
that Kayla can afford?
What's the largest number of
stops that she can afford?
Pause this video and
try to figure that out.
Well, to figure that out,
we just have to solve for S
and then figure out what the largest S is
that satisfies the inequality
once we've solved for S.
So the first thing I would do
is subtract 5.50 from both sides.
When we do that, we are
left with 1.25 or $1.25 S
is less than or equal to 9.50.
And then I would divide
both sides by 1.25.
And since I'm dividing both
sides by a positive value,
it doesn't change the
direction of the inequality,
1.25 and then divide this by 1.25,
9.5 divide by 1.25
is equal to 7.6.
So we get that S needs to be
less than or equal to 7.6.
So we can't take a
fractional number of stops.
So the largest number of
stops that Kayla can take
is going to be seven stops.
She can't take eight,
and she can't take 7 1/2 or 7.6.
So the largest number she
can take is seven stops.
So she can take as many
as seven stops.
And we are done.